hey there wordsmiths I must tell you I
feel quite good about this word
esteem
esteem it's a noun it means respect you
can hold someone in high esteem which
means you have a lot of respect for them
or you can have high self-esteem respect
for yourself this word comes from the
French estim which means to appraise and
to guess at the value of something this
was indeed the original meaning of
esteem was worth or
value let's come up with some similar
words what words can you think of that
contain a similar root to esteem I'm
thinking about that EST especially I'll
give you 10 seconds okay here we
[Music]
go okay here's what I came up with
there's estimate which means to make a
rough guess like estimating how many
jelly beans are in a jar right tying it
back to the root when you're estimating
something you're guessing at its value
or its worth or how many Jelly Beans
there
are esteemed which is another way of
saying the famous or the well-respected
that's how I talk about my work friend
sometimes I'll be like oh yeah my
esteemed colleague Heather she rules hi
Heather inestimable which means
something so precious that it can't even
be given of value like a diamond the
size of a small dog or I belief in you
let's use esteem in a sentence or two
Wanita held her mother's sculptures in
high esteem though the art World never
seemed to get them she respects them a
lot that's what that conventional
expression means to hold something in
high esteem is you really really like it
and that doesn't have to be things that
can also be people you can hold a person
in high esteem let's do another one
brolis the troll saw a therapist to talk
through his feelings of low self
esteem good job brolis it's never too
late to take care of yourself in this
house we support trolls that take care
of themselves wordsmiths I hope you know
the value that you possess it is
inestimable it is beyond number remember
that when you're feeling low I believe
in you and I also believe that you can
learn anything David out